una explosión en el aeropuerto de adén
interrumpió la llegada del nuevo
gobierno de gm
minutos después comenzaron los disparos
y la desesperación entre las personas
que corrieron para protegerse un ataque
sorpresivo que desde el ejecutivo
atribuyen a los rebeldes hutíes la
milicia apoyada por irán de una segunda
explosión provocó graves destrozos en el
área mientras algunas personas
intentaron socorrer a los heridos otros
no pudieron sobrevivir en el avión
llegado de arabia saudita se encontraban
los integrantes del nuevo gabinete de
coalición yemení incluyendo al primer
ministro ma jin abdul malik hechos que
fueron trasladados al palacio de
gobierno cerca de donde se escuchó una
nueva explosión el mandatario envió un
fuerte mensaje a los agresores
el gobierno está en adén para quedarse y
ejercer sus funciones y operaciones con
la firme voluntad de nuestro pueblo los
actos de terror no nos impedirán hacer
nuestro trabajo
e
los ataques aparentemente coordinados
ocurren luego de que el ejecutivo de
yemen reconocido internacionalmente y
los separatistas del sur acordarán un
gobierno compartido un movimiento
interpretado como un frente común contra
los rebeldes hutíes que se han apoderado
de la capital saná y buena parte del
norte del país y jazztel